let's talk about the government's
flagship welfare reform universal credit
last week on this show the Labour Party
position changed from pause and fix to
scrapping it altogether but benefit
combines six separate payments into one
and aims to ensure that work pays and
people don't become trapped on welfare
and while the concept has been welcomed
largely execution has had a few teething
problems well joining us to discuss all
of this is the shadow attorney-general
baroness Chakrabarti and thanks for
being with us and I want to start off
with Universal Credit and last week John
MacDonald the Shadow Chancellor said
that it will have to go effectively
saying that Labor's position would be to
get rid of it and what I'm a little bit
unclear about is what you'd like to
replace it with well can I just say I
know you described the position as
changing from pause and fix to scrapping
I understand that dramatic language will
make you think that this is a complete
change of policy but in the end people
need to be supported when they're out of
work when they're on low paid work they
need to be supported in a number of ways
including via benefits so whether you
end up changing the name of a benefit or
changing the structure of a benefit in
the end what's important is the end of
austerity and people having the money
that they need to live to stay alive in
the sixth wealthiest economy on earth so
are you saying that labor might not
scrap Universal Credit what I'm saying
is that I don't think Universal Credit
in its current form is sustainable and
that's why we're urging the government
to to stop the rollout now because it's
causing such hardship to people the idea
the theoretical idea that you could have
one simple benefit rather than people
having to apply for lots of benefits
always appeal to me in a theory the
problem with the Universal Credit as it
now is under this government is that
it's being used to cut people's benefits
to penalize people for having too many
children to penalize the disabled and
other vulnerable people to be the notion
of a simple simpler benefit system great
idea but not if you're adding austerity
to it so if you're saying are you saying
then that if enough money was put into
universal credit you'd actually be happy
to see it today well I personally I
think the term Universal Credit is now
such a toxic brand the
would be very hard to rebuild trust in
it but we are talking with the people
who've been affected we're talking with
the charities who have been trying to to
paper over the cracks and support some
of the most vulnerable people in society
including via food banks we're working
with them talking with them to try and
work out the most practical way to make
things better and if you contrast what
we're trying to do working with civil
society with what the government's doing
including gagging clauses into contracts
that the government has with with
charities and other third parties I
think that's a very very different
approach the gating clauses in
particular something that you're
concerned well you know as a shadow
attorney you can imagine and with a
human rights and free speech background
you can you can imagine that was pretty
shocked to learn of that contracts
between the DWP that gesture mcveigh's
Department and charities include clauses
that preclude the charities from
criticizing the Secretary of State the
department or Universal Credit that's
completely unacceptable
and I think quite possibly unenforceable
in our court so margaret Greenwood has
written to estimate they urging her to
come to Parliament and make very
publicly clear that these these gagging
clauses will not be enforced and they
will not continue in any any new
contracts between government and third
parties
now lots of things to discuss them on
the program and before we get to some of
the other issues I am keen to talk to
you about anti-semitism because you of
course authored the report into
anti-semitism over the summer we've had
and several stories allegations coming
forward and about alleged anti-semitism
in the Labor Party so I'm quite keen to
talk to you about some of those with
your report for reference so I think we
can look at some thing that you wrote in
your report which is this and it's
always a sundry to compare the actions
of Jewish people or institutions to
those of Hitler or the Nazis now in 2013
Jeremy Corbyn it emerged over the summer
and said that Palestinians in the West
Bank live under occupation of the very
sort that would be recognized by many
people in Europe who suffered occupation
during the Second World War so by your
definition that would be in century was
that like what incendiary by the way
doesn't mean an
he submitted no quite so let me put it
like this by the time I was looking at
the nature of discourse within the party
by definition we had a problem that that
needed to be addressed and I was trying
to set down some guidelines for people
who want to you know to make very
important arguments but not make them in
a way that is going to just
automatically get people's backs and I
understand I don't I know this is before
you report yeah would you say those
comments were incensed I think that I
stand by my advice to everybody which is
to make your human rights critiques and
and Jeremy like me as a lifelong human
rights defender and he is quite right to
draw people's attention to the plight of
the Palestinians but I think that it is
better if possible given the rise of the
far right given the rise of
anti-semitism in Europe is better to
make those human rights arguments
without comparison to to the Nazis and
now in another section you talk about
Jewish stereotyping and anti-semitic
conspiracy tropes and you say and this
about that I'm not saying that this is
endemic but any seasoned activist who
says that they are completely unaware of
any such discourse must be wholly
insensitive or completely in denial and
and I just want to talk to you about
Peter wills been reelected to the
National Executive Committee and who was
recorded as saying that he's never seen
any anti-semitism in the party so it's
the insensitive or in denial well I
don't know but I stand by when I said
which is there's been a real issue and I
do understand that some people will say
that they've not personally experienced
it well guess what if you're not Jewish
you're not going to necessarily
personally experienced it and maybe you
have been insensitive to it or you know
maybe it's just you're speaking for your
own personal experience but I think
about racism of any kind and or frankly
misogyny or any other kind of
discrimination or hey the thing about it
is that you've got to try and listen to
the broader experience you've got to try
to understand things that that you've
not experienced yourself
trying to that was what I was trying to
advocate then and continue to advocating
that would you feel more comfortable he
hadn't been reelected to the executive
committee um possibly you know but but
he has apologized and people have to
have the opportunity to reflect and
learn and change and be more sensitive
and become aware of other people's
experiences as Jeremy Corbyn said at
conference and by the way that was a
conference of you know it sort of 15,000
people who came together in this
democratic moment and generally speaking
behaved quite well with each other he
said we need to learn to listen more and
shout less and that I think is it is a
crucial point not just not just in the
labour party but in British politics and
politics more generally that's what I
would advocate and now your course leave
shadow giant Attorney General so justice
and completely Affairs if you like your
brief and so I'm interested to get your
thoughts on the case of Karen white who
is the transgender prisoner convicted
rapist who was moved into a women's
prison where she then committed sexual
assault now she's been sentenced now to
life in prison should she spend the rest
of her sentence in a male prison or a
female prison do you think so here's my
position on the trans woman issue I do
believe in self-identification but
nonetheless there are some people who
should not be incarcerated together now
there's a wealth of case law from the
Court of Human Rights in Strasbourg for
example about racists who have been put
in prison cells with members of minority
communities now they might be of the
same sex and therefore they're in the
right prison you would say but those two
people should never have been put in a
Cell together because that would make
one inherently vulnerable so it's more
about her previous convictions rather
about the gender the resident I think
that I think there are some people who
should not be housed together whether in
a refuge whether in a woman's refuge or
whether in a woman's prison or an other
vulnerable
so should the Ministry of Justice policy
be updated then in a minute it is saying
that transgender prisoners should be
located in the part of the estate
consistent with the gender they identify
I think that you've just got to be more
specific than that some people are a
danger to other particular people and
they should not be housed or put in
refuge or put in prison together these
are a minute it's a common-sense
administrative practical responsible
solutions to people's vulnerability it's
not about whether a trans woman is a
woman like me or a woman like you it's
it's much more specific I think and
before the interview in Tacoma also very
keen to get your thoughts on Jamal
khashoggi who is the journalist who has
not been seen after entering the Saudi
consulate and in Turkey very concerning
story clearly and what do you think the
UK government needs to do now I think we
need to be much more robust and Emily
Thornbury our shadow foreign secretary
is written in The Observer today a very
robust piece about how we need to start
calling out Saudi Arabia I'm not saying
that it's just the Conservative
government you know Robin Cook was
heartbroken about not being able to
follow through on ethical foreign policy
largely because of things like arms
sales to the Middle East and we've got
to we've got to stop being more
consistent in our criticisms of of other
governments and as Emily's written today
you know would the government be quite
so reticent if this kind of behavior
were being conducted by Iran Russia
other countries possibly not and so are
you talking about like stopping Armour
sales sanctions what potential
potentially I mean um you know we cannot
be arming Saudi Arabia without some
without real assurances that those arms
are not being used against innocent
civilians in Yemen against dissidents
and Saudi Arabia itself you know Saudi
Arabia should be in the dock when it
comes to human rights abuses including
women's rights abuses on this planet and
we need to be more consistent in our
attitude to human rights okay Baroness
check our body language